TONIGHT'S THE SPEED GAME IS
PUPPET GOVERNMENT.
PUPPET GOVERMENT.
NOW WE REALIZE YOU GUYS ARE
DEFINITELY NOT PUPPETS.
BUT HOT DOG, SQUIRREL AND THE
ANIMITROIC GEPPETTO CALLING
HIMSELF PAUL, I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO GIVE ME AS MANY EXAMPLES
OF PUPPET LEGISLATION AS YOU
CAN.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN.
PAUL.
>> MOMENT LIFE BEGINS
DETERMINED TO BE WHEN THE
EYES ARE GLUED ON.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. PERFECT.
STAR.
>> OBAMACARE.
>> NO, STAR, NO, IT'S--
THAT'S--
>> CHRIS: ALL RIGHT, FINE.
POINTS.
HOT DOG.
>> EQUAL PAY FOR
MARIONETTES.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
PAUL F.
>> ROE V. WAKA WAKA.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
PAUL F.
>> CONSENT NEEDED BEFORE A
FOOT CAN ENTER A SOCK.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
HOT DOG.
>> OH, MY TURN?
>> CHRIS: YES.
>> PINNOCHIO WILL NOW HAVE
THE RIGHT TO MARRY A REAL
BOY.